[Music]
Uh
Yes, hello, the title of this session is a little bit bigger.
I wanted to get some cool air in the air conditioner 10 minutes before I arrived home after a hot summer recently, so I made it grandiose now.  I
think you'll know in 25 minutes whether you knew it
or not. I'll try to solve it for a short time.
First of all, I think I should introduce myself first. I'm Just and I
'm working at Microsoft as Cloud Advocate.
If you are curious about my personal life, if you see below, there
is an introduction page for it, so it would be nice to have a look.  If
you do it inside the blackout at least once, I'm very happy and I think I can wake up again. Well,
first of all, I
think I should write a brief introduction about why I started this project.  I
think there might be some people who want to match the two, so first around the
end of May, there is a YouTube channel that I am running now.  I
've done this once with .
A lot of people were interested in age coding at that time,
but if you're curious about the content, you can go to the address below here and
see it. You can see other content besides this one.  I think it
would be nice to see it.
It's me, but the test person had so much fun and talked well, so
this is now I've been playing golf a
lot now.  Now, looking at the situation before going abroad, I
knew that Koreans were very high, and now I
know that it has become hotter in the meantime, so I know that Korea is
very hot.
There were a lot of them,
so I was really worried. But, after hearing that world,
I have a Raspberry Pi at home,
so let's try making one myself.  Let's make
it look a little longer, so let's
add a little more function and upgrade it. I
thought about this.
That way, I started even if the trade was in a deadlock. I
started confidently. But like this, starting is always an
achievement, but  Well, it got stuck here and there, right now,
so it didn't become as easy as I thought.  I had
to make it in the end, but I did it, but I made it
difficult. So, in order to organize some of those parts and to
share them with you, I
have a history now.
Now, first of all, this is
home automation.  In order to implement it, I think I need to briefly explain some of the hardware and some of the overall
architecture.
I had a 0 Raspberry Pi at home after rolling around.  I
know it came out, but my model
was an old model that came out in about 2014.
But it was about the Berry Pi to Model b.  I
decided to use the old model because I wanted to just use what I had without having to buy , and yesterday the ultimate goal was to make a
universal remote control by integrating all the remote controls in the house into one Raspberry Pi.
Most of the people in the house are infrared remote controllers.
First of all, we
needed an attachable sensor module of Raspberry Pi that can replace the infrared signal of this remote control. We needed an infrared sensor
module.
Fortunately, these sensor modules are already  Working at Amazon, I
was able to sell and buy a lot at this online shopping mall. But fortunately, I
had a chance, so I didn't take it away from him like this, but
he gave it to Jesus, so I received it and used
it.  There is now a receiver.
This is the ir sensor.
This is the part that receives the infrared signal earlier, and this part is the
one that emits the infrared signal.  It's a representative that was stored and learned.
But this one does that and now uses the saved remote control data to
send signals to home appliances as if the Raspberry Pi is not a real remote.  The
infrared sensor is now necessary,
so this is my overall big architecture
So, the server
works as if it acts as a remote
control.  I
did it. Then, the high material needed for 2 tunneling, the
tunnel data
was not capsuled. I ordered the capsule to make a line like this to the Azure temple, and
5 rises. From the outside, if you run only the Azure firmware point, you can receive everything.
Yes, it has now become a lot with Power's Kappa Automate so that aptitude wishes can be executed in the mobile app.
Now I've been working on making products even so that I can turn off and on my phone.
Here, I think you can see it as a big architecture.
Now, I'll tell you from the first shovel I did to implement this architecture as it is. The
first thing I had to do was this raspberry  I'm changing the pi into a remote control
because, as I mentioned briefly earlier, my ultimate goal is to
change the swear words because the Raspberry Pi has a remote control that fits, but
to do that, install the infrared sensor module and set it up now
Actually, this part was very difficult because the way to say it
was okay to do the 7 of the society, but while setting it up,
there was a day there.
It didn't fit, but even if I did it for a long time,
it was data from 2018 and 2019, but nevertheless, it
didn't fit my situation,
so I
tried this by continuing to weave trial and error.  It was a success.
According to the manual every year, the teenager who came by accident, once the module that receives the sensor works, but the
sent shape does not work, or conversely, the module that sends it works, but it
does not receive it because of ignorance. There was a problem.  I
did it how I did it. One of
them said oh well, then I can't
forget it. It happened a few times by
accident.
That's right, so I'll send you that blog again later,
so I've done a lot of hard work based on old data.
4 Remote control When registering the raspberry pi
My chin is interesting. There is a beautiful database all over the world.
There is a data byte that has all the remote control data in the world.
There is one. If you
look at it here, it seems like there are 50,000 remote controls,
but now the problem is that the most recent update is in 2018.  If you
search, there are
things about famous brands, but things that are not so famous,
for example, things that are famous only in Korea, there are no such things.  I
had to create the remote control data myself. Making
this remote control data again is reflected in the infrared sensor in this way.
But when I do that, there is still light around it, so
depending on the direction, this infrared signal is interfered with. So,
when I press the same button and capture this again, the same infrared signal
doesn't come. So I'll show you this here.  It was actually capturing the data,
but everyone turned it into a program called Turan, Egg, Now,
Well.  You know, the
bigger the number block, the more
complicated the remote control. The more complex the remote control, the bigger this number
block.
After catching it, the only thing I had trouble with was the tv remote control, because this tv
remote control was the simplest among the ones in my house, so I made it with
this one.
Then the TV turns on behind me, but
now it's called a smart TV,
so it takes time to print like this.
Uh, in the end, I can see that the Netflix screen is visible on my screen.
And next time, I will take it again through the command irs & don't use TV switch off, and then I'll
give it to the
cap.  We were able to confirm that this worked properly for a month.
So, among the entire architecture, they said that the
Raspberry Pi was attached to Wi-Fi and used as a remote control, so we
proceeded.
There will be some people who are curious about the air conditioner because I didn't come up with a big story, but
for now, it's not that important, so I'll move on with the TV remote control first.
Control it through vld 1 and I'll tell you about the shoveling for the part. First of all, it's a remote control.
Now, ir send sand once tv switch on, even send a
command to make it. 3 people are great with that command.
I already have it so I'm
going to
use it to
make a very simple remote server api server.
It's a very simple nose that's about a line
So when you import a package called a synod at lirr Now, if you look at
ir If you look at that line 6, ir sand sand once The device is big, but it's like this.
So it's
the same as the dream command called irs and sand once tv switch on that you saw in the video clip before.  I
created an object called control and
created a hot water island called a village and a red war called hand on switch off to
create whats the simplest remote controller.  I
made two endpoints using cell phone Archer. Second &p is remote switch
one.
Second &p is remote switch second. I called a function. In
this way, this is also now an api server.
I saw it, but I really had some doubts about it. But actually, it
only takes about 20 lines of code to create a server on this API, and
about being able to develop something really quickly, the
Note 3 s can really develop that quickly, and toss
typing  It's very good when developing a poc or something like
this. I felt it a lot this time.
Let's see if
I look at the bottom right now, in the ppu visual studio code, I
connected to the raspberry pi, and now I'm starting to turn it into a pay server with mpm stark.
Yes, I'm back.
Hit the 4005 port and it's the switch-on
day, so
now it's done. This time, I'm going to run the switch-off lottery.
It's working properly. And I
called it in the home network called Air 1 7 2.3 public 1.29 In other words, yesterday's computer was also in the home network, so I
was able to control it directly like this.  I
made and uploaded my server now. Now everything like home network works.
But work only works within the home network. But our ultimate
goal is to make it remotely difficult to cut from outside the house.  You
have to expose it. The
first method is probably one method that exposes the entire home network. But, as you know,
this is a method that is never recommended for security reasons.
I want to selectively expose it like this so that data can come and go.  You
can easily make a tunnel by doing it.
Well, there is an application here for Raspberry Pi as well, so download it on
Raspberry
Pi and run it.  Because of this, only the walnut-specific pi
server is exposed to the Internet.
Now, I'll show you like this. You'll see the screen.
I'm here. I'll look at the right side. Now, if you look at the right side, I do
n't do the same here with the Raspberry Pi,
so I'm going to do it http
4,000 port.  If you
use this url instead of the ip address and port number, you
can run it from the outside, that is, from outside the home network.
So, I
created a url to create Angry at random, and now I can run it from outside the home network.
Now, we have
implemented even creating a cpu channel so that we can access from the public Internet to the home network.
Now, it's almost done, it's almost done, and
now what's left is, then,
how do you go from the public cloud to this way from the cloud?  In the
case of the version, it doesn't matter, but we use the free version for now. In the
case of the free version, it changes every time you run the bank group,
so it's very unreasonable to use this directly.
If you cover this channel once, then I
made a bus son to block it with a random url that keeps changing with this angle.  For those of
you who are curious about
ak point ns / js coms / if you
go into fung ash no jasram , there is a great reference of silver so it would
be nice to have a look at it because it is very easy to make.  As
you can see, a perl is a string or click to the
tv device side through the body.
This is
Angry, which accepts Angry, and Yu, which continues to change. Deco &p,
combine the two, and use the combined url to
make a non-3 sati Seoul call through x os.
Years made it easy. This way
we can caption that random new wife that makes the angle come. Okay, I
'll show you again. Similarly, uh, I
'm uploading the z that I used for the api for mpm.
Rotate the robe again Then, just in front, another origin was
created. Now that the random yoari made like this has just been created and
distributed now, put it in the western country that is surrounded by the white spots like this,
and then run it again.  After doing
this, if you do this, your financial wish is just ready. Now, the address of the
function says that you can re-care the rpi, the flux, and the flux again.  If you
do it like this, it will turn on and
switch on. If you look down, you can see the heat value keeps coming out. Now,
this time, I saw the power of 5%, and Fred's only TV was turned off.
Hey, you can see the endpoint d mote /
s upper and the call.
That's right, I made fossa well with Azure Functions like
this.
Rather, it's already done.
So, I decided to make a mobile app. But now, making a mobile app
itself is also very difficult.  I
bought it to see if there is a way to make a mobile app very easily. But
now, there
is a power platform, which is what Microsoft is talking about. Through this power platform, you
can easily create applications.  If you are
curious about more details related to ak point
ms / cs kang / power If you go back to the platform, you
will be able to know more about it.
Then Power Automate I'll really tell you.  I
can't give it to you, but
one thing to do in the automate workflow is that the function was
created earlier and overwritten. There is
only a call to Perth's son. So, call &p and
insert the api key.  I
came from the app and now I send it right
away.
There are Excel hum lines. You
can use the s function as if you used the x functions.
So, there is a power automate home appliance sb motor controller that I made earlier.
Well, if you look here, there
is an on button and an off button.  In this way,
send that variable sometime. When the off button is pressed, send the tv off in
this way.  There's something that has to be done. I've
written everything up to the application like this. So, that's how I
configured my overall architecture. Then I'll
actually upload it.
After hearing only one new url,
let's move this to Azure Functions. Now we're going to modify the environmental variables of the infant leisure pump system.
Now, in the strike app, you only need to call Seongcheon, so
now I'm actually running my app because I've now established the app like this, so I'm actually
running my app.  I'll see it on the right side. So,
like this, you have to switch
on and switcher, and you
can see when the result is this Jester.
So I actually went and tried this in front of Taebaek Mountain.
You must be nice. So, after turning on and turning on, you will see my
flex screen for a moment from the back.
Now, you will see that the trap is turned off among my specials. It
was mixed. So, in the end, the screen now says TV turn afternoon.
Like this, I actually filmed turning the TV on and off through a hospitality phone.  I've
been doing things that I've used and implemented home automation through, but I've learned a lot in the middle of this.
Actually, I've suffered a lot, but I've learned a lot.
First of all,
I've created the remote control data.  He said that he probably
didn't do this, so he actually did the remote control data
chapter.
The second one was that he made an api app with node js.
It's easy using the row group in the third row of the following. I made tunneling and
exposed only the necessary parts of the home network by playing games.  I
ordered Capsule 1 and worked like this so that it would not be known from the outside.
Lastly, I even had the experience of developing a mobile app using Power Yes and Power Automate.
In fact, I
don't think you have to worry about the fact that all of your home appliances support Wi-Fi,
but now more and more home appliances
are still using irs remote control in the far infrared method,
so
if you're curious,  I thought it would be nice to try this kind of work once.
Also, what's interesting is that among the developers around the world,
some of the developers around the world have already made and released
it.
So, it seems to be up to about 100 of the contents I have prepared.
Now, instead, I want to give you a homework assignment.
So, in case I have a Raspberry Pi or I am still planning to buy a file,
so if you say you want to try it, please bring 2 links and
go to my  I saw it on the blog, so it
would be nice if you read it and follow it.
So hot summer hot summer After work, 10 minutes before I arrived home, I
talked about the harrow that shoveled the air conditioner coolly with force.
Thank you.  I've
never heard about the air conditioner.
Actually, I failed while making the remote control data for the kid's
air conditioner.  I
don't know why, but it's
so hot to greet you.